pendant qu'au regard des magnétos kelly
mady dans l'oreille un truc incroyable
que l'amas de la cité qui pendant l'été
non c'est vrai quoi
mais la voilà là on va s'intéresser à ce
sujet les mains vous êtes des tickets
pour les garçons c'est un truc de fou
ce n'est pas son frère parce qu'il ya un
fond s'appelle jean reno
[Rires]
attendez neymar vous avez créé cet été
vous a dit quoi j'étais je dormais avec
plaisir girafe à ce moment-là à nantes
où là il m'a envoyé un pouce ouais il
madier aux ayew et moi j'ai répondu à
une girafe
ah ouais c'était mon inspiration est
ensuite m'a demandé si j'étais sur paris
arrive une panne en bas j'ai dit non je
suis avec les girafes les chauffer diouf
bah ouais c'est fou et à lyon paris et
donc mario sait pas vers la montée
quittant la techno
[Applaudissements]
c'est cette affaire c'est un quad est ce
que ça pourrait être votre style il est
très beau il est mignon bas il est
mignon et alors je vous le dis moi j'ai
rencontré et il est vraiment très sympa
franchement y'a très sympa pg lui
demande de lui faire gagner les matches
importants il est jamais là quand on
n'est pas dans une tête il écrit moi
j'ai vu hyper sympa et j'ai rencontré il
m'a dit ah oui et j'en vois une girafe
sophie la girafe
mais franchement il est hyper sympa